Blake Lively has a very relatable reason
for why she's not attending tonight's
Met Gala Blake told reporters last week
that she'll be watching from the comfort
of her couch and then she joked that
she'll be wearing her dress from last
year which is just iconic if you
remember Blake's dress last year was a
Versace Statue of Liberty inspired gown
that she just looked incredible in but
honestly like what doesn't she look
great in what made Blake's dress even
more incredible is the fact that it the
color of it was changed last minute at
last year's red carpet she told LaLa
Anthony that she arrived in Copper and
then her dress was painted to a green
she also pointed to the Dress saying
this is architecture from the Empire
State Building lots of New York City
references I mean this is just chef's
kiss